*musique* *puis un klaxon de voiture*
Les amis, le thread de Reddit vous avait beaucoup plu !
Mais alors, du coup, après ça,
j'me suis baladé sur Reddit.
Et mec, c'est génial !
C'est une mine d'OR !
Y'a des threads qui parlent de TOUT et de RIEN !
Et il y en a un qui m'a fait particulièrement rire,
qui s'appelle CrappyDesign.
En gros, c'est des photos du quotidien
d'endroits ou d'objets du quotidien,
mais qui sont mal foutus,
mais vraiment très très mal foutus !
A tel point qu'on se demande comment c'est possible que des mecs aient faits ça sans se rendre compte de la connerie !
Aujourd'hui, nous allons ensemble regarder
les meilleures de ces images.
Alors ce que j'aime bien aussi avec Reddit, c'est que dans les threads, les images changent tous les jours
ou toutes les semaines vu que c'est un système de vote.
Par exemple, si t'as vu ce thread il y a une semaine
et que tu retournes dessus aujourd'hui,
bah il y aura des nouveaux trucs.
ET C'EST ÇA QU'J'ADORE !
Bref je découvre Reddit un peu après la guerre,
après que tout le monde sache ce que c'est,
mais bon, mieux vaut tard que jamais,
comme on dit dans le milieu quand on est un LOOSER !
Alors je le dit très souvent !
Ça commence par ça:
"OK, donc là je suis juste confus sur ce que je dois faire quand je me retrouve dans cette situation."
*bruit de grillion*
*Rire*
Mec.
Le panneau EXIT, panneau qu'on utilise en plus
si jamais y a un feu, tu vois !
Et là, *Rire* là, vraiment y a le feu t'es pas bien.
Et t'es au pied du panneau "Sortie",
t'as réussi, tu vas t'en sortir,
NON NON NON gamin, cette porte n'est pas une sortie.
C'est horrible, mec
En plus c'est quoi si c'est pas une sortie ?
Mec, je suis désolé, les portes comme ça,
c'est totalement des sorties.
Si ça se trouve, c'est une sortie
et le mec à mit ça pour faire genre
c'est pas une sortie,
comme ça si y a un feu, les gens meurent...
Je regarde beaucoup trop de thrillers et de reportages sur les psychopathes, ça va pas du tout.
Ce banc qui charge des téléphones
à l'aide de l'énergie solaire est placé sous un arbre,
dans l'ombre d'un immeuble.
Ça coûte grave de la thune en plus
de faire ces putains de bancs.
Mettez-le au moins là où il fait BEAU !
Je pensais qu'on avait appris ça quand on avait 4 ans.
Vraiment, le dos d'une tasse, ben voilà c'est rond quoi....
Ça peut vraiment pas aller dans le carré d'une assiette...
À moins que le carré soit plus grand que le rond !
Mais là, ça ne marche PAS DU TOUT.
Celui-là, il est un peu ingrat, je vous l'avoue.
Parce que c'est évident que cette assiette est faite
pour servir les espressos...
Dans des toutes petites tasses, tu sais....
Et lui, il a demandé un café allongé.
Voire un  américain, si c'est un fils d'eup.
Du coup, le serveur était triste, parce qu'il a que
cette assiette-là et il sait qu'elle rentre pas dans le carré.
BREF, ouais je prends la défense
de tout et n'importe quoi, ouais...
"ORANGES", c'est quoi le problème ?
Baaaah, ah ben oui, OK, j'ai compris.
Quand je comprends, je me mets un doigt dans l'oreille, c'est bien ça.
C'est un savon à l'orange.
Normalement un savon à l'orange, dessus,
y a des photos d'oranges.
Mais là, comme c'était Halloween,
ils ont mis des photos de citrouilles,
alors les gens étaient troublés
et pensaient que c'était à la citrouille,
alors que non, c'est à l'orange...
Quand on voit un fruit ou un légume sur un produit,
eh ben, on imagine que le produit SENT
le fruit et légume en question.
Je suis en train de faire une thèse sur du savon,
C'EST BON !
Clément, il faut qu'on prenne des vacances !
Quelle horreur, oooh mec....
Il lui on mit un putain de poteau
devant sa porte d'entrée.
Naaaan, mais c'est pas possible, what ?
S'il est malin, il peut devenir hyper musclé en 1 an.
Il se fixe une condition:
dès que je sors ou rentre de chez moi,
je fais le drapeau sur ce poteau pendant 10 secondes.
Emballé, pesé !
Les muscles arrivent en fin d'année,
comme ça !
Avec le bonus de prime de salaire.
En vrai c'est horrible.
Ortnite is great.
Arrêtez, là, toutes les petites usines, là,
toutes les petites usines.
Toutes les petites usines, les petites usines mimis, là.
Arrêtez de sortir des produits dérivés faits avec le cul !
Il faut les faire avec vos mains,
des fesses ne sont pas capables
de les faire correctement, je vous assure.
Le placement du capteur dans cette salle de bains.
Aaah, OK, il est trop loin, et du coup,
il faut tout le temps ramener ta main.
Ingénieur
Je veux faire beaucoup d'années d'études
pour embêter les utilisateurs de toilettes.
OK, il y a un problème de conception.
Maintenant, je vais te dire un truc:
au moins, c'est clair que le capteur est loin
et qu'il faut mettre ta main devant pour que l'eau coule.
Des fois, gros, le capteur est proche, mais il marche pas !
Tu mets ta main, t'es là t'es comme un con, tu fais ça, là,
sous l'eau, là, pour qu'il détecte, tu tapotes dessus, là,
comme ça, c'est chiant !
On en parle pas assez de ces capteurs qui marchent pas !
Nan, mais en vrai. *rire*
Quand un Américain dessine Peter Pan...
Pourquoi il a des flèches et un gun ?
Mec, les flèches sont même pas dans le carquois !
*cri d'oiseau agonisant*
''Comment je suis supposé lire ça ?''
C'est quoi cette merde ?
C'est quoi, qu'est-ce que ça fait là ?
Ah, c'est que ça doit parler d'huile ou un truc comme ça
et du coup, ils ont voulu montrer de quoi ils parlaient, mais ils l'ont mis sur le texte, c'est malin.
Faut pas écrire des livres quand on sait pas faire, hein.
''Ohh, j'adore ce 'cube' magique'.'
*rire* C'est pas du tout un cuuuube.
Ah, mais peut-être que c'est la marque, juste.
Et peut-être que ça, en fait, ça s'appelle le ''Hand Sport''.
Donc t'as voulu faire une  blague
alors que tout est clair sur ce packaging.
C'est pas bien.
*rire*
....Mais mec ! Mais quelle idée !
En plus, y a de l'herbe partout autour !
Quelle idée !  Ça me rend fou !
La vraie question, quand on voit ça,
c'est qui a posé le deuxième banc ? Et quel banc est le deuxième ?
*petit rire* Qui a tort dans l'histoire ? *rire*
Celui-là, il est fouuuuu: ''Famous Asia''.
Donc un célèbre restaurant asiatique,
et ils ont mis un chef it-a-lien !
*petit rire*
WOUUUH ! Nique la logique.
Et il est content, il est content en plus d'être là,
de représenter l'Asie.
Est-ce qu'il a même 1 % d'Asie en lui, cet homme ?
NON. *petit rire*
''Increase your ass'' (Améliorer votre fessier)
Comment tu peux faire des erreurs comme ça ?
Au lieu de mettre ça, comme ça,
où tout est compréhensible,
ils ont mis ça, comme ÇA !
On dirait que ça veut dire ''Giant Ass'',
se qui veut dire ''cul géant''.
C'est génial !
*rire*
Comment  l'esprit humain peut-il être si perverti ?
Y a vraiment un semblant de testicule,  là.
C'est pas du tout un motif sexuel. *rire*
Regardez, petit test pour vérifier
si vous avez l'esprit perverti ou pas.
*lit* The mmh mmh countdown.
Le quoi coutdown exactement ?
Est-ce que vous pouvez me dire ?
J'arrive pas à lire.
Si vous avez lu "anal", vous avez l'esprit perverti.
Car il y a marqué FINAL.
C'est pour ça que le "A" de gauche
est plus gros que le "A" de droite.
Moi je vais pas vous mytho,
je l'avais vu direct.
*lit* The what countdown *rire* c'est pas ça.
Et je n'ai qu'une parole, vous le savez.
Les mecs, vous faites une partie "trash" et une partie "recyclable".
On voit bien qu'il n'y a qu'un sac,
qu'il n'y a pas deux parties !
Ne faites pas genre
si c'est pour mettre qu'un sac en dessous !
Arrêtez un peu !
On vous voit, nous !
Oooh nooon, franchement, les gars,
vous avez pas pensé que...
Je comprends votre dentifrice, vous voulez montrer
aux gens qu'il rend les dents blanche et tout...
Je comprend très bien.
Mais mettre trois putain de blancs ensemble,
avec en dessous marqué "white power"...
C'est pas bon, il faut éviter à tout prix !
Comme faire une vidéo
qui contient des hommes politiques !
Quoi ?
Hé, et si on faisait une porte genre…
pour aller sur un trottoir ?
"Oh pas con", allez !
C'est un terrain de pétanque, en vrai, pas un trottoir,
ma vanne était à chier, mais bon, vous êtes habitués.
Mais ce qu'il est le plus troublant sur cette image,
c'est que si j'y vais,
j'ai vraiment envie de passer par la porte.
*petit rire*
J'ai pas envie d'enjamber, j'ai envie d'ouvrir ce truc et de le refermer derrière moi pour montrer "je suis dedans".
C'est psychologique, nan, ça vous fais pas ça ?
C'est génial, là,
on découvre des choses sur le cerveau humain.
Ah ! Ces vidéos, là, c'est de la recherche, hein c'est... c'est travaillé !
Ah, tiens tiens tiens !
Asus Republic of Gamers !
Cette poignée n'est pas... homologuée !
C'est pour rattraper les scolioses qu'on chope
à force d'être assis de travers sur nos chaises ?
Genre c'est plus simple à porter
quand la poignée n'est pas centrée ?
Asus, je viens de faire une théorie pour vous défendre,
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un PC Gamer
suite à cette vidéo, je vous aime.
OK, les amis, là, c'est fou.
T'es en soirée, un pote renverse un peu son verre sur toi.
TAC, tu tapes dans son verre, HOP t'en as plein l'épaule.
Mais t'as aussi très envie de faire pipi.
Tu peux faire l'un ou l'autre,
pas les deux en même temps.
Ton dernier espoir, c'est quoi ?
C'est tomber sur ça, mec !
tu peux te secher l'epaule pendant que tu pisses !
*petit rire*
Nan, en vrai, la vérité, ça va être horrible.
C'est-à-dire que pendant que tu urines,
il y a un mec, là, qui est comme ça,
qui met ses mains sous le truc, comme ça,
mais qui ne veut pas te déranger pendant que tu urines,
mais il veut avoir les mains sèches
avant de retourner au repas.
C'est terrible... Ahhh !
Mais naaaaan !
Il manquait un cube et ils ont mis 2 lettres
dans le dernier, du coup, c'est l'enfer !
Ça fait partie de ces images hyper insatisfaisantes.
Venez, on se cotise, on lui donne le dernier cube.
Non, c'est trop triste.
C'est quoi cette affiche ?
Eh mec, franchement, c'est un crappy design,
mais c'est bien fait.
L'endroit est respecté, on a visé l'entre-yeux,
on n'a pas dégradé... c'est clean !
On devrait tous se balader avec un tuyau comme ça.
La vie serait bien meilleure.
Ce plug USB brille plus que le soleil.
Je le veux, c'est génial !
T'en branches partout sur toutes tes prises chez toi,
tu fais une soirée, pas besoin d'acheter de lights.
C'est déjà ambiance... Non, c'est une idée de merde.
Le gars est sur un jeu mobile.
Apparemment, c'est un jeu réservé aux majeurs.
Donc le jeu met un avertissement:
il veut qu'un parent accepte que son enfant y joue.
Les mecs ont eu une idée, ils ont mis une interface:
S'il te plaît, peux-tu confirmer que tu es le parent
ou responsable légal en complétant ce calcul.
68-59 !
Genre, il n'y a que les parents qui peuvent résoudre ça.
Même Natsu saurait résoudre ça, je te jure.
Faut arrêter.
La peinture dans cette toilette publique.
Quelle horreur !
Putain, on dirait qu'un enfant a joué avec du, du...
du gâteau au chocolat.
OK, ici, on a un pommeau de douche
qui est apparemment pas bien.
Ils ont mis la barre de l'autre côté,
c'est génial !
Je pensais même pas que c'était possible.
Hahaha, mec, la main !
Les ingénieurs des poubelles se sont alliés
avec les ingénieurs des escaliers.
Pour créer leur plus belle pièce.
Franchement, c'est beau.
Ça nique le couloir du milieu, mais c'est beau.
Bravo, les gars !
C'est scandaleux !
Le mec a acheté un mug.
Et sur le code-barres du magasin, c'est écrit:
OK pour le lave-vaisselle et le micro-ondes.
Quand tu retires l'étiquette,
le constructeur de la tasse, lui, a marqué:
non, pas OK.
C'est du foutage de gueule.
Là, c'est hyper grave.
Le T-shirt PlayStation, les couleurs de rond,
carré, X, triangle ne sont pas respectés.
Ils ont inversé les couleurs.
Ils ont mis le triangle bleu au lieu de le mettre vert.
Ils ont mis le rond vert au lieu de le mettre rouge.
Oh, ça me brise le coeur, je ne veux pas aller plus loin !
Effacez-moi ça, ça dégage !
On finit sur celui-là.
Il est parfait !
C'est un panneau qui dit qu'il faut ralentir
parce qu'il y a une aire de jeu d'enfants.
Ils mettent ça !
Ils mettent vraiment ça !
Mais les mecs, là, quand on voit ce panneau...
Mais vos enfants !
Les regardez pas faire !
Croyez pas que c'est normal !
Si vos enfants jouent comme ça, c'est pas normal !
Pour vous, on dirait que tout le monde joue comme ça.
Non !
Les amis c'est la fin de ce petit tour
sur le thread crappy design de Reddit.
Ça m'a bien amusé.
J'en ai vu plein d'autres aussi qui sont sympa.
Dans la vraie vie, ça m'intéresse,
si vous croisez des trucs comme ça, qui ont un design qui va pas du tout
Twittez-moi ! Faite une petite photo et tweetez-moi, pensez à moi et mettez-moi bien
Je suis très friand de ça.
Ça me fait trop rire.
De toute façon, l'erreur est bête et gentille,
sans conséquences.
Ça me fait toujours rire.
Si ça a un côté mignon autour de ça, c'est toujours mignon
Je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo.
Pour parler de...
Eh bien, je sais de quoi !
Je vais vous le dire tout de suite.
La prochaine fois, on va parler de...
*musique*